if I was to add a player to this
tournament either Gelfand well i think
is a very good player who doesn't get my
chances to play or vey well if you had
chronic then it would be top 10 all
around it's hard to get better than that
well I guess Granicus name that pops to
mind it would be Kasparov I think he
still will be considerable threat to
anyone my wife might get quite bored
here so why not give her a shot well one
interesting Blair might be after Sarah
one at the last time I look at these
games if they really will any beat a lot
of strong players and you'd be surprised
yes there's technique even at his age um
if I could add one player probably one
of the Chinese players either ding Liren
or away ding Liren if another a chess
tournament needs to have a Chinese and
Indian player a Russian and American so
probably I believe I the Chinese player
or maybe someone from South America so
the way we have some following in all
the continents I with a hammer yeah I
because I really wanna get my revenge
today he messed up pretty badly in
fantasy football so and now it's okay
from history wow that's that's a tough
one I would have to say Bobby Fischer
Fischer you have to say Fisher right
otherwise and then I'm gonna let you out
of the room either but with Fischer
pettersen from history Oh Fisher of
course of course definitely okay well I
have to say Fisher right i mean if ya if
especially I think Rex would be happy
they would be interesting to see how he
would do against modern top players just
world is missing the games that fishes
did not play he stopped to when he was
too young so I would give him the
possibility to him how to be all the
best players here now Bobby Fischer
worth either Bobby Fischer or feral
Capablanca I wouldn't mind seeing
someone like McHale Mikkel towel playing
either so probably one of those two no I
was always dreaming to meet me hey
Italian not really even to play with him
but rather just to spend some time as
him to chat with him and even just to to
look at him I would like I would like to
play kappa so have a blanket would be
very nice I think capablanca to see if
his style what may be perceived as
simple chess we work today